in space third time's a charm for SpaceX  and liftoff the Falcon takes flight  propelling the deep-space climate  Observatory on a million mile journey to  protect our planet Earth after several  delays because of radar issues and bad  weather this space xo rocket finally  made it off the launch pad the rocket  carries discover that's a satellite that  will orbit the Sun to warn us about  solar storms that could affect our  electrical grid the modern space race  includes all nations the european space  agency launched for the first time on  wednesday a prototype spacecraft capable  of returning to earth the intermediate  experimental vehicle or ixv is wingless  it's roughly the size of an automobile  scientists hope the craft will pave the  way towards Europe's first reusable  space transportation system